what do Kim jong-un Mahmoud Abbas and
Steve Bannon have in common they messed
with the wrong bad hombre we will
analyze Trump's castration of Bannon and
the important lessons it holds for
international relations then this day in
history
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
what a day I you know I think we're
gonna have to reshoot that Christmas
morning video that we did we released a
Christmas morning video a couple weeks
ago and you know it the daily wire did
it had me and drew an Alicia and Ben was
in a bunny suit but we're gonna have to
reshoot it now because I now know what
Ben Shapiro really looks like on
Christmas morning not a lot to talk
about before we get to that we have to
talk about something just as important
maybe more important and very very
fitting for the tone of today's show
that is American history tellers by
Wonder II so first thing you got to do
this a great new podcast go subscribe to
American history tellers on Apple
podcasts or wherever you listen to
podcasts go do that right now I talk all
the time about how nobody reads any
history you should it is I think the
best bang for your buck and you educate
inform innit listen to read you're gonna
get by studying history so how well do
you really know history you know that
we're talking about the stories that
make up America and Americans everything
from the words we speak the ideas that
we share the values that we admire and
the freedoms we defend they can all be
traced to our shared history trouble is
nobody knows anything about history if
you read like one history book you will
know more about that topic
and virtually anybody else in the
country I know what you're thinking you
don't have time to read history you
don't you didn't have time to study it
that's fine
tune in to this great podcast it puts
you inside the shoes of everyday people
in the time place and event that made
history the Cold War the the American
Revolution prohibition the space racers
there's one on the Gold Rush it will
show you how history affected them their
families and it affects you today
this is hosted by Lindsey Graham no not
that Lindsey Graham is not it would be
funny though it would be funny to hear
his voice doing a podcast no this is
Lindsey Graham who's a history buff he's
teamed up with PhD historians to bring
you a new take on history so they take a
first person's narrative with sound
design to really get history stuck in
your mind it's a really innovative way
to do it it's really tailored for the
medium it's a good show you should
definitely check it out the first six
episodes for this new serie
covered the cold war this is something
that I studied a lot when I was in
college the stories of the Cold War are
endlessly enlightening you could keep
studying them they're having
ramifications certainly today you know
one way to debunk a lot of nonsense news
stories about Russia is to actually
learn about our relationship with Russia
in the Cold War so the show premieres
Tuesday January 3rd you can start
listening to the first episode right now
listen to the rest of my show first but
that make sure you subscribe so that you
can listen to that show today it's
really really good American history
tellers on Apple podcasts or wherever
else you listen American history tellers
subscribe today ok talk about American
history well and what a great opening to
the third season of America it's only
January 3rd but this is the third season
of America the reality show the second
season ended in a kind of boring way I
don't know if you remember the last
episodes it was tax reform lower
corporate tax rates blah blah blah now
we've got new cast members better plot
lines new conflicts so let's get into
this first episode it all began when
quotes leaked this morning that Steve
Bannon allegedly gave to author Michael
Wolfe who's now writing a book called
fire and fury inside the Trump White
House so according to these quotes Steve
Bannon calls Donald jr. a traitor
unpatriotic and says that he's going to
get cracked like an egg on national
television so of course the White House
issued this response I want you to get
this way hey Briggs I want you to find
this fancy boy Eliot Ness I want him
dead I want his family dead
I want his house burned to the ground I
want to go to middle no no no I'm only
joking I'm only joking Trump's response
was far more vicious than Al Capone it
this this response is so incredible I am
just gonna read it verbatim it's a
little long don't worry you will not
want to miss one syllable president
Trump this is a statement from the
president Steve Bannon has nothing to do
with me or my presidency when he was
fired he not only lost his job he lost
his mind
Steve was a staffer who all worked for
me after I had already won the
nomination by defeating 17 candidates
often described as the most talented
field ever assembled in the Republican
Party now that he is on his own steve is
learning
winning isn't as easy as I make it look
Steve had very little to do with our
historic victory which was delivered by
the Forgotten men and women of this
country yet Steve had everything to do
with the loss of a Senate seat in
Alabama held for more than 30 years by
Republicans Steve doesn't represent my
base he's only in it for himself
Steve pretends to be at war with the
media which he calls the opposition
party yet he spent his time at the White
House leaking false information to the
media to make himself seem far more
important than he was it is the only
thing he does well Steve was rarely in a
one-on-one meeting with me and only
pretends to have had influence to fool a
few people with no access and no clue
whom he helped write phony books we have
many great republican members of
congress and candidates who are very
supportive of the make America great
again agenda like me they love the
United States of America and are helping
to finally take our country back and
build it up rather than simply seeking
to burn it all down and with that Rosie
O'Donnell learned that Trump actually
went very easy on her 10 years ago
this is brutal this is classic Trump
vintage Trump watch the language he says
when he was fired now Steve Bannon
insisted when he left the White House
that he chose to leave he could better
support the Magga Genda from outside of
the White House from Breitbart or
wherever Trump totally smacks that down
and by the way Trump held his fire at
the time didn't he Trump wouldn't when
Bannon was saying all these things
Trump played very nicely he didn't
contradict him it's only when Bannon
turned on Trump that we get this
Smackdown more language he says he lost
his mind what Trump is telling you is
Steve Bannon is not credible do not
believe it's not just he has a vendetta
against me or he's a an angry
ex-employee who wants to get back at me
say he lost his mind he's saying his
very capacities of reason are not
credible he then goes on and says Steve
was a staffer not a strategist not the
ex-ceo not the blah blah blah he was a
staffer who's he worked for he works for
me
numero uno and and we have these
memories these images of Trump
that says you're fired you're fired
that's why he uses that word in the in
the statement that's why he calls him a
staffer Donald Trump is the guy who
decides who gets fired that's his
catchphrase for 15 years he brings up
the Senate seat in Alabama now why does
he pounce
now the steve bandit has been causing
trouble for donald trump for a few
months now for more than a few months
now why does he pounce now because steve
bandhans credibility is that the lowest
has ever been steve Bannon
through sheer tyranny of will made
Republicans lose the Alabama Senate seat
for the first time in decades we lost
Alabama this is impossible so he strikes
him exactly when he's weakest when he's
most vulnerable when he knows he can pry
ban and write-off of the of the actual
Trump base and and look at even just the
wording pretend he uses the word pretend
twice Steve just pretends that he had
this has influence he's just a pretend
guy he uses the word fool he uses the
word phony what why Donald Trump knows
when words stick to people ask little
Marco s client ed asked crooked Hillary
s glow energy Jeb on and on and on he's
using these words because Bannon has no
political experience and after Alabama
he has no demonstrated political skill
other than his brief association with
Donald Trump so why pretend because
Donald because Steve Annan rather is
playing the political guru he's playing
Karl Rove he's playing David Axelrod
he's playing a guy who's been in
politics for a long time to my knowledge
he's worked on one campaign granted he
entered that campaign at a pretty high
level for a brief period of time but he
there was a tweet that went out
yesterday and it said Steve Bannon is
constantly walking around thinking that
he's in his own Martin Scorsese biopic
he's got the Layla piano song playing in
the background that's the image you get
it isn't the real political strategy he
isn't the real met Ernie he isn't the
real Machiavelli
he's just playing one on TV and that's
something for our culture in which so
many things are merely performed for
television rather than a legitimate and
with substance he's gluing this to a
Steve Bannon and what does he close on
he closes on build it up and burn
down you get these two different images
we know Steve Bannon is famous for
saying wants to burn it down burn that
lady dog to the ground burn it down but
what is Donald Trump's image he's a
builder he's worked in construction he
builds things he's gonna build a big
beautiful wall I know how to build
things
he's contrasting himself with Steve
Bannon what he does which is
constructive with what Steve Bannon does
which is destructive and he's lumping
him in with what he said about Democrats
on Twitter just a couple days ago which
is that I get results and all of these
other people are just obstructing and
attacking and breaking things apart
really the classic word choice classic
trumpian word choice so there's a lot to
be learned from this statement not just
from Trump's personal behavior also
about his foreign policy first let's
let's cover the basic thing with the
word choice Donald Trump is a New Yorker
and New Yorkers do not take any guff
from anybody and I don't mean guff that
is act that's actually the line of Billy
Joel used to use to end his shows you
would play whatever song you know you'd
attorney and say don't take any guff
from anybody don't do it this is a this
is a real thing this is prevalent in New
York I'm sure elsewhere in the country
as well but it's a real sense and Billy
Joel Donald Trump these guys are from
Queens the Bronx Long Island don't do it
don't ever take any guff from anybody
not even once why the preeminent
military historian Don Kagan once told
me that he knew that passages of
Thucydides history of the Peloponnesian
War were true because of the Brooklyn
schoolyard sometimes it takes a thief to
catch a thief
sometimes it takes a bully to catch a
bully everybody I know who knows Donald
Trump and I know a few people who have
worked for him known him socially knows
family they all talk about his loyalty
if you're loyal to Trump he's loyal to
you what happens when you turn on Trump
I'll just ask Rosie O'Donnell in 2006
completely unprovoked Rosie went on the
view to criticize Trump for giving Miss
USA Tara Connor a second chance after it
was revealed that she drank and partied
underage I know something none of us
have ever done
so Trump decided not to not to D crown
her and Rosie criticized him during that
segment on the view she called him a
snake oil salesman she
accused him of having gone bankrupt
multiple times and as she attacked his
multiple marriages so what did Trump do
he just kind of he said that's okay I'm
not gonna respond right that's what he
did no he did this well Rosie O'Donnell
is disgusting I mean both inside and out
you take a look at her she's a slob she
talks like a like a truck driver
Rosie attacked me personally because I
was very happy when her talk show failed
the other thing that failed and this was
a real monster
and everybody was suing there was her
magazine her magazine called Rosie was a
total disaster so I loved it I gloat
over it I think it's wonderful because I
like to see bad people fail
Rosie failed I'm happy about it she's
basically a disaster well she called me
a snake oil salesman and you know coming
from Rosie that's pretty low because
when you look at her and when you see
the mind the mind is is weak I don't see
it I don't get it I never understood how
does she even get on television I
believe Barbara made a terrible mistake
putting a run and I think Barbara's
probably paying a big price if I were
running the view I'd fire Rosie I mean
I'd look at right in that fat ugly face
it's very subtle
typical settled from Donald Trump but
this is how New Yorkers talk there are
three components to glean from what he
just said it was blunt it was brutal and
it was funny it was funny you can't I
just let you can't help but laugh even
if it's so mean it's mean-spirited us it
is funny this is the last part that
everybody seems to miss so the big news
yesterday was kim jongwan right Kim
jong-un had been boasting that he has a
nuclear button on his desk so Trump
responded quote North Korean leader Kim
jong-un has stated that the nuclear
button on his desk is it all always
there at all times will someone from his
depleted and food starved regime please
inform him that I too have a nuclear
button but it is a much bigger and more
powerful one than his and my button
works now the pearl clutches on both the
left and the right started wailing and
gnashing their teeth I love this
response for three reasons one it's a
response to a genuine threat from North
Korea so North Korea is saying we have a
button we're gonna send missiles and
blow up your cities we are not going
to listen to you we're not going to
abide by international norms and there's
nothing you can do about it that's a
genuine threat and it tests the
credibility of the United States and
there has to be some sort of response
now also and there was a response and
we've been working for a long time and
we have a lot of military assets in the
region also it's a joke it's a joke and
it cuts little Rocketman down to size so
this is the word this is the worst thing
to do to these people it kim jeong-hoon
is trying to seem like a serious scary
leader and what is trump do he just
makes fun of him
it just says oh yeah that's cute oh by
the way my button works because you
can't get your missiles to fire now the
other reason the third reason why I
really enjoyed this tweet is it worked
just hours after this tweet North Korea
reopened a line of communication that
had been closed off with South Korea for
two years it had been closed off during
Barack Obama and they reopened at this
line of attack why is it I wonder there
has to be a credible threat of force and
Donald Trump seems like a crazy person
many people even in this country think
that he's a crazy person this works to
his advantage he's he knows that it
works to his advantage you can see it
from the tweets I think anybody who
still believes that he's just randomly
tweeting off whatever thought pops into
his head hasn't been paying attention
for a year and hasn't been paying
attention to the shocking effectiveness
of his administration so it did work Kim
jong-un somewhere in a little bunker in
Pyongyang a little rocket man is quaking
in his boots because he doesn't know
what President of the United States
would ever tweet something like that
this guy and it's and it's credible so
this isn't something new by the way this
line of attack my buttons bigger than
your button this followed precisely the
line of attack that Trump had during the
2016 campaigns do you remember when
Marco Rubio started doing his Don
Rickles impression when that campaign
was on its last legs
he's always - which is why I don't
understand why his hands are the size of
someone who's 5 - I
like this and you know what they say
about men with small hands
you can't trust them he said I had small
hands actually I'm six-three not sick
stupid he said I had small hands much
smaller I never hurt I never heard that
one before I've always had people say
Donald's you have the most beautiful
hands
he hit my hands nobody has ever hit my
hands I've never heard of this what look
at those hands are they small hands he
referred to my hands if they're small
something else must be small I guarantee
you there's no problem I guarantee
welcome to America America in 22 anout
2018 so Trump was called sophomoric for
engaging in this measuring contest but
he doesn't take any guff from anybody
george w bush was in many ways a very
good president but he failed on this
front he failed marvelously because he
refused to hit back at the scores of
people who were attacking him very
unfairly and those lies those innuendos
drowned his presidency maybe in the
historical record he will be vindicated
to some degree but they drowned out his
presidency and Trump won't let that
happen he fights back Ben has talked for
years about this when a bully hits you
you hit back twice as hard
people accused Trump of being a bully
maybe it is but it it takes a thief to
catch a thief and sometimes it takes a
bully to subdue a bully now what does
all of this mean for broader policy a
lot unlike Barack Obama whose entire
foreign policy consisted of strategic
patience and leading from behind and
phony red lines and more flexibility
after my election Vladimir and empty
threats and apologies Donald Trump is
confrontational his opponents say
confrontation threatens world peace
it'll kill us all in a nuclear war if we
only hug our enemies and appease them
and give them whatever they want then
then they will let us all live in peace
another Republican president understood
how ridiculous those fantasies are those
who would trade our freedom for the soup
kitchen of the welfare state have told
us they have a utopian solution of peace
without victory they call their policy
accommodation and they say if we'll only
avoid any direct confrontation with the
enemy he'll forget his evil ways and
learn to love us Alexander Hamilton said
a nation which can prefer disgrace to
danger
is prepared for a master and deserves
one now let's set the record straight
there's no argument over the choice
between peace and war but there's only
one guaranteed way you can have peace
and you can have it in the next second
surrender admittedly there's a risk in
any course we follow other than this but
every lesson of history tells us that
the greater risk lies in appeasement and
this is the specter our well-meaning
liberal friends refuse to face that
their policy of accommodation is
appeasement and it gives no choice
between peace and war only between fight
or surrender that's the only guarantee
of peace and what a piece that is that's
the piece of slavery there is no choice
between peace and war only fight and
surrender we had Victor Davis Hanson on
the show a few weeks ago to talk about
his new book the second world wars in
that book he makes an excellent
observation he writes throughout history
conflict had always broken out between
enemies when the appearance of
deterrence the material and spiritual
likelihood of using greater military
power successfully against an aggressive
enemy vanished the appearance of
deterrence you see that when the
appearance of deterrence to the to the
aggressive enemy is there a more perfect
description of the Obama doctrine don't
worry about whatever we say don't worry
we'll never actually use our military
might to a decisive degree a total
surrender of American credibility in one
exchange he actually told Russia he told
the the leader of Russia Medvedev that
he was blustering in threats against the
regime I will have more flexibility
after my election and Medvedev responded
admitted transmits this information for
Vladimir da you hook the quote was
caught on an open mic these are the
policies that threaten world peace and
we saw it happen in real time that the
joke goes they told me if I voted for
John McCain we would get a third war in
the Middle East and they were right I
voted for John McCain and we got a third
war in the Middle East that's exactly
what happened during eight years of
Barack Obama no decisive victories just
more Quagmire's incredible amounts of
death because we were simply managing
wars that the administration in
Washington was half-heartedly fighting
that it didn't want to win that it
didn't want to directly
challenged anybody they wanted to lead
from behind what did that get us it got
us chaos and destruction it lost his
whole States throughout the Middle East
and it was a major knock to our allies
and to American credibility Donald Trump
doesn't do that it isn't that he's
playing for DHS that's what they accuse
us of said they say you think he's
playing for DHS he's not it's not that
he's playing for DHS it's that he has
credibility when it counts
so Barack Obama there was a piece in The
New York Times which very occasionally I
will read and the New York Times said
Obama's lies compared to Trump's lies
Trump has all of these lies and Obama
had very few lies but all of Trump's
lies are basically to the tune of I
exercise every day yeah I'm a really
cool guy everybody loves me I had a big
crowd sighs right those are Trump lies
these little egotistical minor white
lies Barack Obama's lyza or if you like
your doctor you can keep your doctor
that is more important that he admitted
to blustering to the American people to
diluting the American people he a
Jonathan Gruber the the architect of
Obamacare boasted about conning the
American people his foreign policy
adviser Ben Rhodes boasted about conning
the American people those are the lies
that matter so you might say well Trump
doesn't have any credibility he's always
exaggerating he's always talking about
his crowd sighs okay he doesn't have
credibility on his crowd sizes he
doesn't have credibility on trivial
superficial nonsense but where it counts
he's had credibility he's followed
through before the UN vote condemning
the United States for moving its embassy
in Israel to Jerusalem another promise
that was followed through after
countless administrations and Republican
administrations promised to do and they
didn't follow through Trump did follow
through but before that vote Trump
threatened and said the United States is
watching the votes and there would be
consequences nikki Haley reiterated
precisely as much the vote proceeded
anyway and what happened if this were
Barack Obama if it were another fake red
line nothing would have happened but
with Trump the United States immediately
cut almost 4% of the UN's total budget
not just our contribution to the UN the
4% of the whole thing and that's just a
warning shot we've given Pakistan 33
billion dollars in aid over the past 15
years we had allocated 250 million in
aid for the fiscal year twenty third
twenty eight
steam we haven't given them that aid yet
and we're going to withhold those funds
until they play ball no more mr. nice
America how about aid to the Palestinian
Authority will the u.s. maintain its
present level of funding of the UN
relief Works Agency for Palestinian
refugees in light of the General
Assembly of Jerusalem resolution pushed
by the Palestinians and the Palestinian
UN representatives threat to unleash
quote all the weapons we have in the UN
so I think the president has basically
said that he doesn't want to give any
additional funding or stop funding until
the Palestinians are agreeing to come
back to the negotiation table and what
we saw with the resolution was not
helpful to the situation we're trying to
move for a peace process but if that
doesn't happen the president is not
going to continue to fund that you tell
him sister be still my beating heart
emits pitter-pattering out of my chest
absolutely right now I mentioned the
military historian Donald Kagan earlier
he has an excellent book on the origins
of war and the preservation of peace
that book is called on the origins of
war in the preservation of peace because
he's not the most creative title er in
the world but he makes an excellent
point one of the great threats to peace
one of the great causes of war
throughout history has been when great
powers get complacent they rest on their
laurels they believe that threats will
suffice without the demonstration of
resolve to use force so let's take two
examples the Second Punic War in the 3rd
century BC and the Second World War
what are those wars have in common in
both cases a dominant power was
perceived to be complacent in the case
of the second Punic War that was Rome in
the Second World War Britain and so a
lesser but angry power rose up surely a
mine or a defeated power would never
challenge the dominant power again right
surely North Korea would never really
launch a rocket right that's okay we
don't need to worry I would never really
happened coincidentally both of those
wars were among the deadliest conflicts
of all time ancient historians
considered the second Punic War the
greatest in history world war ii is the
single deadliest conflict in world
history with death estimated between 50
and 80 million this is this is a real
so listen we have got to get to this day
in history before we get to this day in
history when will will conclude with
some thoughts on how this all ties
together but before we get to this day
in history I have to tell you about
something very important I have to tell
you about up-side so how are your things
to do in 2018 checklist coming along
mine is a work in progress I don't I
don't do checklists I do I kind of just
sticky notes all over the wall like I'm
schizophrenic or something
I do have one thing on mine that belongs
to every business travelers list book
your next business trip at upside comm
so you know when you're booking business
travel first of all travel is such a
degrading experience these days flying
is so awful they cram you into little
tin cans and put you in the cargo hold
and maybe they'll give you a little
thing of peanuts but no more pretzels
because they might or too salty or too
expensive or something so when you're
booking your business trip when you do
you I promise you will get a better
business travel experience and a free
pair of Bose Soundlink wireless
headphones more on that in a second
here's why you love upside comm only
upside has customer service specialists
who look out for you every step of the
way on your business trip they handle
any problem that might pop up their team
is hard at work 24/7 to make sure your
flight hotel and rental car all go off
without a hitch
they're available on demand by phone
chat email what wherever you need them
sometimes I don't want to call somebody
or joining you just chat email is very
easy only up side monitor is your
business trip around the clock its
proactively keeps you posted on
everything from the weather to changing
your flight home just so you can adjust
your meeting schedule I one time got
caught I was in the UK and my flight had
been cancelled like the ticket was
cancelled but nobody let me know this I
found this out 15 hours before the
flight it was very frustrating and very
expensive don't let that happen to you
have you ever experienced that level of
customer service on a business trip that
upside offers absolutely not so all of
that plus it has great prices for
flights hotels and rental cars to get
your free pair Bose Soundlink wireless
headphones those are really good
headphones just booked your first
business trip with up side by going to
up side comm slash do you know do you
know Marshall can you guess
cough FA
cough FA CoV f e f e that is upside calm
slash cough FAC o v f EF e to claim your
Bose Soundlink wireless headphones
upside comm you deserve a better
business trip headphones are available
while supplies last
you must be your first up side purchase
$600 minimum purchase required but on
business travel that is nothing and C
side for complete details okay now it is
time oh you know god I'm Marshall you've
reminded me that's too bad we were gonna
give a great this day in history it's a
very personal one it's near and dear to
my heart but if you're on Facebook or
YouTube I got to say goodbye to you if
you're on the daily wire comm right now
thank you for subscribing you helped
keep the lights on you help keep cafe in
my cup if not go to daily wire.com right
now what do you get you'll get me you'll
get the Andrew Klavan show you get the
Ben Shapiro show you get no ads on the
website yeah yeah it's all really nice
the leftist here's tumblr you're gonna
need it you're gonna need it I promise
you the threat of a nuclear war and the
and the button on Trump's desk that is a
much less severe danger to you than the
flood of leftist tears that are pouring
out when they read those tweets make
sure we're cutting off aid to the
Palestinian Authority or cutting off aid
to Pakistan you really really need to
get this leftist here's tumblr or you're
gonna be washed away it's gonna be like
that scene in a deep impact you know and
the giant wave is washing away Morgan
Freeman or whatever that is what's going
to happen to you so go to daily
wired.com we'll be right back
[Music]
okay it's time for this day in history
this day in history a topic near and
dear to my heart on this day in history
in 1961 the United States cut off
diplomatic relations with Cuba I know is
terrible
luckily the president stockpiled all of
his Cuban cigars before that happened
now after two years of deteriorating
relations we closed our embassy in
Havana
I love Cuba I traveled there for a
weekend in June with our senior producer
Jonathan hay and daily wire god-king
Jeremy boring
they have very delicious stogies their
beautiful beaches truly wonderful people
but the United States has bungled our
relations with that island ever since
Fidel Castro seized power in 1959 and
this has a lot to do with what we're
talking about today those errors almost
plunged the world into global nuclear
conflict during the Cuban Missile Crisis
these decisions say a lot about
confrontation and appeasement Bill
Buckley William F Buckley Jr when he
started the National Review founded the
modern conservative movement he refused
to support Dwight Eisenhower because he
considered him too soft on communism
Cuba is the prime example of that
in early 1960 Castro signed a trade
treaty with the Soviet Union in response
the US began funding and training group
of Cuban expats to overthrow the
dictator all well and good good to get a
commie out of there trouble is that
campaign was tempered it was moderate it
was bit by bit so Castro began stealing
even more private property to this day
Cuba is essentially a mafia nation as a
mafia run nation with the Castro's at
the helm of it all so in response then
to that the Castro's a stealing private
property including countless American
interests the US began to implement
certain cutbacks in trade with Cuba too
little too late
two months later just a few months into
his presidency John F Kennedy sent the
Cuban exile force into Cuba during the
Bay of Pigs debacle it was a major
failure it was a major setback for the
Kennedy administration just one year
later the United States entered into a
13 day standoff during the Cuban Missile
Crisis the closest the 50-year Cold War
ever came to direct nuclear conflict two
big nuclear buttons
both of which worked on two separate
desks Soviet leader Nikita Khrushchev
had met Kennedy four months earlier and
his impression was that Kennedy was weak
again the perception of weakness the
perception that these people had that
this superpower had lost its resolve he
installed missiles just 90 miles off
American shores with Fidel Castro
chomping at the bit to launch them how
many times had the u.s. weakly
challenged Castro tried to assassinate
have tried to invade in fact many
historians credit Castro's hotheadedness
with helping to convince Khrushchev to
back off now as a result of this bungled
foreign policy the United States was
forced to remove our missiles from
Turkey though fortunately nuclear war
was averted what should we learn from
all of these episodes past and present
peace can only be maintained with the
credible threat of force as Ronald
Reagan put it peace through strength
Teddy Roosevelt said to speak softly and
carry a big stick
but sometimes you can't speak softly
sometimes you have to speak big Lee
especially on Twitter and in those cases
everybody needs to know that we have a
big button on our desks and it works
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Nolt show come back tomorrow we'll do it
all again
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
Hague
supervising producer Mathis clever our
technical producer is Austin Stephens
edited by Alex's and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Cora Mina hair and makeup is by
Jesuit all Vera the Michael null show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for word publishing
2017